microphone there we go
okay there's a button there to press the
microphone
oh it is okay yeah
it's not my thought was Redmond off
Ann Edwards associate attorney general
from the Attorney General's office
uh Matthew Conley Assistant Attorney
General from the Attorney General's
office
okay thank you
so thank you very much for inviting us
to present I'm going to leave for the
most part this presentation Tim Matt
we've handed out to you some concerns
that we've identified some are from the
Attorney General's office for the work
that we've been doing particularly in
um reviewing all of the campaign Finance
forms for the last three and a half
years
but we also have some combined issues
with the Secretary of State's office
they have presented to you earlier in
the session about those and we have had
more conversations so we've made some
modifications and we'd love to chat with
you about those so I'll turn it over to
Matt
thank you very much
um
as attorney Edwards indicated again a
lot of this does Echo what the secretary
of state has already presented to you
folks my understanding is that
um attorney Fitch from the Secretary of
State's office gave you folks a kind of
a little packet of concerns I have some
extra copies of that if anyone if anyone
needs it for any reason
um but uh with that
um we'll just kind of go through it here
if you have any questions please just
so um one of the most frequent issues
that we see just to leave off at the top
there is the alphabet alphabetization of
donors
um a lot of reports and filings that we
see have anywhere between a half dozen
and a dozen donors and when we we issue
people warning letters following up on
errors that we've seen they often the
response is a callback that indicates
what I need to I need to refile and just
alphabetize the the half a dozen people
that appear on that form
um and our response has been well yes
um we would suggest that their that
requirement probably isn't necessary
unless there is a larger number of
donors
um so again what number would be
appropriate would of course be up to you
folks but until it becomes a significant
number of donors
um it's it's probably not necessary to
have most people who have a small number
of donors
um comply or go through that requirement
so
um so we would consider
um a number of maybe 25 or under
um
we have a number of issues with late
filings and the Secretary of State's
office went through this in more detail
and I don't I don't think it's necessary
to go through all of that again
um but we have a number of
both different organizations and amounts
of contributions that trigger different
filing and reporting dates
we while we have not necessarily
explicitly heard that people are
confused about that we are
we are confident that that might be one
reason why we are seeing a number of
late filings is people looking at the
statute and being genuinely confused
about when exactly it is that they are
supposed to be filing
um with the state so we think that
simplifying that scheme of who is
required to register report and file
when would probably alleviate many of
the late filings that we are seeing
um
reporting dovetailing off of that a
little bit
um reporting versus registering
so uh we have been looking at a scheme
where uh folks
not everyone who registers with the
state's campaign Finance reporting
website has to report and vice versa
so we would suggest that having all
entities that participate in this
process have to at least register with
the site
that would we think simplify some
confusion there by just creating the
across-the-board requirement that folks
sign up with the site when they begin
the process when the campaign season
starts
and before we move on from that point so
part of what we do is we enforce the
election laws and if we use an example
of political mailers
those flyers come in the mail to people
they sometimes now they come over social
media as well when those documents come
out the
what happens is depending on how they
have them printed and how they have them
mailed they can keep the organization
that does that can stay under the limit
so if they're one of the political
committees that doesn't have to report
until they expend 2500
and they do a mailer that runs for
fifteen hundred dollars they don't have
to report on that they often
one of the biggest challenges we've had
in the last election cycle is people
don't properly identify who is putting
out the mailer so even if they don't
have to report the expenditure under
66417 they still have to put their
identification on the mailer so that
people know who has put that mailer out
and so we then spend a lot of time
trying to track down people and people
organizations and it's a challenge to do
that and you're trying to do it as
quickly as possible because a lot of
time we call them Anonymous mailers
these Anonymous mailers come out two
weeks before an election and people are
very upset in the community about what's
being said in it and they want to
understand whether it's an accurate
mailer or an inaccurate mailer so they
want to know who's sending it so if all
political committees had to register
even if they don't have to report it
would make things much easier in the
enforcement side of it now we understand
there could be reasons why people might
not want that to happen but that from
our perspective as the enforcement
um so the next item there
um one thing that we are seeing a great
deal and a lot of people they genuinely
don't seem to understand that it's a
requirement is a person or a committee's
filings tend to stop when a campaign or
a candidacy ends they they don't seem to
actually be aware of the requirement
that if there is outstanding debt
outstanding obligations or an
outstanding Surplus that they have to
continue to report until that Surplus or
debt has been satisfied
a clear statement of the law on that
could help to alleviate that but we did
want to bring it to this body's
attention that that is something that
we're seeing a great deal that it it and
it makes a little bit of sense it's kind
of common sense that oh well wait a
minute but I'm not in the game anymore
so why would I continue to report
um just some action being taken to kind
of educate a little bit more and to make
it clear that no no that obligation does
continue to exist beyond the candidacy
or the campaign
um could could alleviate some issues
that that we are seeing and Reporting
um item e under there
um so it's another thing that we don't
neces on this point we don't necessarily
have a recommendation but it was
something that we wanted to bring to
this body's attention was that we are
seeing a number of un itemized receipts
that are under the threshold the
triggering threshold of fifty dollars on
many reports that are totaling up into
values of many not many but several
thousands of dollars with many of those
amounts being under 25
um so again this it's looking like if we
had to speculate uh fundraising
instances where people are just giving a
few dollars at a time but that is
totaling up to amounts on these reports
in the thousands of dollars
and again just to raise another Point
here
there's nothing unlawful about this at
all one of the challenges though under
664 colon six Roman one is that if an
individual donor donor makes
contributions that in the aggregate
exceed 200 then those have to be totaled
so when you have a lot of small
donations that are made and perhaps are
made at different events it's it's just
so that the legislature understands it's
virtually impossible for the Attorney
General's office to determine whether or
not there is there are aggregate
contributions of 200 or more
Connie I'm sorry representative that's
okay uh thank you
are those are do you know what kind of
races those are are those perhaps more
House of Representative races or they
usually going to go up the chain to the
larger races
so
um I spoke to the member of our team who
uh who actually brought that item to our
attention I do not have the breakdown of
what that is I could try to get that
data for you
um
the the next point there this is a
a practical one that we're seeing is
arithmetic and handwriting
um there's been a significant amount of
our enforcement attention spent on just
trying to discern what what is being
written on a paper and double checking
people's arithmetic on the reports that
they have filed
um
it's it's a
a it's a it's a process um I will say
that
um the only thing that we could
um offer there is if there was a scheme
where we had
um more finding Authority for inaccurate
reports illegible
reports for uh repeat offenders for
example that could help us to to make it
clear that we need people to be filing
those reports accurately legibly so that
we can do our job efficiently
and make it make it clear that those
reports need need to be clear if they're
being filed
sorry I thought we had a question there
thank you for taking my question uh
similar to the question representative
Lane just asked I'm not looking for data
here but do you have a feel for what
percentage of the reports have
legibility or accuracy difficulties just
an idea
I know it's obviously it sounds like
enough work that you're concerned about
it but five percent ten percent
just just a
to Ballpark it would probably be about
10 or 15 but again that's not a hard
number that's what I'm looking for and
it's not going to come back to haunt you
um how many man hours would you say go
into your Democrat
how many attorney person hours
um would you say go into I appreciate
that would go into
um as you can tell I'm not awake yet so
that one like
um
uh would go into deciphering these um
Egyptian hieroglyphics that are
sometimes on these reports
um so there is
um a there are two pieces to it there
was
um the hours spent probably
um
probably a few dozen hours spent
determining what the schemes were going
to be for uh
are warning letters and replying to
these folks that was probably a a couple
dozen hours with a couple members of our
team in the beginning in terms of the
ongoing
processing of these and going through
them and Discerning
um were
um and one one point that I'll clarify
is that there is
um on as an ongoing matter we have a
paralegal who goes through these she's
the point person on Discerning these on
an ongoing basis it's probably been well
over a hundred hours
um dedicated to to Discerning
um arithmetic issues and eligibility
issues and if I could hop in so we've
been doing this for a long time and what
we realize is that some candidates just
don't are not computer savvy and they're
not using computers
as a result some won't use the online
campaign Finance system
that system also had some challenges
relatively recently and so that caused
perhaps an influx of more written
reports but we do have certain
individuals who have filed over the
years and have been
notified over the years that they are
filing with Mac errors and illegible
language and they continue to file that
way so for some individuals I believe
that it's a tactic for how to
yeah you don't get to do that when you
sit in the big seat you know
um
so it's safe to say it's 150 hours
once again I'm not going to sit there
and demand an audit log right
um probably paying a paralegal probably
all in around 25 plus
probably more well I've heard the States
you know it's probably more public so
fully fully burdened probably more like
50 or more yeah total comp probably 50
so I can't get someone to rake my lawn
for 25 yeah well you know when you live
with the beautiful people in Hanover I
understand but
for the for those of us regular folks
all right okay two so it's costing us
thirty five hundred dollars at least in
man hours at a minimum
that's probably bad math am I missing a
zero
um
it's costing us a lot of money to do
this because we just won't file online
yes
it's a challenge and I know that the
Secretary of State's office with
conversations we've had recently
is working on plans for how individuals
can come to the Secretary of State's
office and be able to have access to a
computer for folks who don't have access
to a computer and there will be
individuals there who could also answer
questions for them to help them be able
so yeah well wouldn't it be cheaper to
save 300 bucks and just give the
Secretary of State's office a thousand
dollars set up a desktop people can use
like wouldn't that be cheaper and faster
and fix everything
I guess it's like a rhetorical question
can we get a thousand dollars to get the
Secretary of State a a uh it doesn't
even need to be a good laptop most
people who testify in front of this work
group eventually learn they don't have
to answer representative various
questions
just just thinking out loud here it's
like you know if you need a if you need
a Macbook or something
that wouldn't resolve
completely resolve the difficulty for
people who live up like in the North End
of the state
because of travel time too are they
getting over a thousand dollars in
contributions
I doubt it well I don't know the answer
to that but I'm just so yeah
I'm thinking if we uh as has been
discussed in the subcommittee meeting if
we
worked on having a mandatory requirement
to use the online system
I think we'd have to make a reasonable
accommodation for people who were not
don't have the skills or the equipment
to do it online that's and I don't know
what that reasonable accommodation would
be at this point
I've had to take into account the entire
length of time it takes to get to a
place where they could use a computer it
seems to me
I think yeah the Secretary of State
could could work with local libraries to
give
um candidates especially for the house
who are all over may not have fancy
computers in their houses access
yes
the kind of thing you know the ones that
well I think we could develop a solution
I mean that's an example of of an idea
that you know in the face of it sounds
useful thank you representative
mirrorhead
and thank you uh representative Mary so
and yet he somehow survived with the
yes we can
do you have a comment or a question
representative Blaine do you have a
comment or a question you'd like to
share with us yes could we please move
on to the testimony in front of us yes
thank you
so the one thing we'd like to add with
respect to the finding Authority is that
we have authority to find political
committees for late filings
but we don't have the authority to find
political committees for
illegible
filings or incorrectly added filings and
things like that and I I would hope that
I would offer that in the 26 years that
I've been at the Attorney General's
office we do not run rampant with
finding Authority so this isn't
something where we're looking to find
individuals or political committees but
it's helpful to have that as a deterrent
in place because we what we often have
is we have the ability to charge someone
with a misdemeanor and the chances of us
charging someone with a misdemeanor
because they're writing eligibly on a
thank you
so those were the issues that we wanted
to bring to this body's attention
regarding things that we directly are
seeing on reports common problems that
we're seeing
um I'll also move on or rather I'll move
on here to issues that we have talked
with the Secretary of State about and
there's there's some common ground on
how how we would address or how we
believe those issues should be addressed
and we have some common thoughts on them
um the Secretary of State's office has
already distinguished it to this body
that there are currently nine different
types of registrants I won't go through
that again I don't think that's a good
use of anybody's time here but the one
that we did want to note
um and the one that we have had real
conversations on is
um political committees versus political
committees that have an election or that
have electioneering as a major purpose
um after our review of the law and have
included the
the the sections of RSA 664 colon 2 that
um lay those organizations out
there is little meaningful difference
um between when
the
characteristics that define both of
those types of organizations and so we
have we are now considering them uh one
and the same we're looking primarily at
the two thousand five hundred dollar
threshold
um in defining those organizations there
um so again there's there is this
this blurring of
um what those organizations are and
again that does kind of feed into
um concerns that the secretary of state
has already raised regarding the
complexity of the different types of
organizations which in turn can go back
to other issues such as when different
organizations meeting different
thresholds have different reporting
deadlines
um and amounts excuse me
um
there is some language in RSA 664 of a
candidate versus a candidate committee
to expand on that thought a little bit
more and again the secretary of state
does that in their handout I won't go
through it exhaustively
there are sections that denote the
responsibilities of candidates
the responsibilities of candidate
committees and then it breaks down the
responsibilities of financial agents
treasurers
but also seems to use the word candidate
interchangeably with some of those
responsibilities and some of those terms
and so it may be worth looking at the
sections that of RSA 664 that the
secretary of state has raised to see if
if that language can be unified
to make it clear that this is that a
candidate would or a candidate or a
financial agent whatever term the
legislature uses or chooses rather could
be used in all of those instances to to
clear up any ambiguity there
um
or there are
um some organizations 501cs in
particular that are not required under
the law to disclose the identities of
their contributors they fall into the
requirements of uh disclosure amounts
Etc but they're explicitly not required
to disclose the identities of who is
contributing to them
um again nothing nothing unlawful being
raised before this body we just want to
point out that that is that is how we
and the Secretary of State are reading
the law and if there is something there
that this body would like to revisit
then
that's that is entirely
um up to your discretion but again just
something that we wanted to raise in
terms of how it is that we're reading
the law
and if I could just add so one of the
one of the reasons behind campaign
Finance reports is so that similar to
the example that we gave earlier on the
political mailers is so that if somebody
wants to go search through the reports
they can determine
who is contributing to different
candidates or in support or opposed to
different measures on the ballot and
they can access that information
people will
complain to us when they are not happy
with the disclosure information and they
feel like they can't determine who is
funding an effort to support or defeat a
candidate and so we raise this issue
because this is what the law says this
is how the law is enforced but just so
that you're aware of the fact that this
is one of the areas that we sometimes
receive complaints and when I say
sometimes it's not a huge number of
complaints but people do complain to us
at different times that they find it
frustrating that they can't figure out
who is contributing to certain
organizations
um
under 664 the definition of political
advertising continues to include the
word implicitly
um we there are two concerns there one
um for the uninitiated in um campaign
Finance law and campaign election law
that could be confusing that a word
continues to appear in the statute that
has been declared unconstitutional as a
practical concern from our perspective
we have made it our practice to whenever
we issue any kind of a warning letter a
cease and desist letter we take whenever
we take any kind of action on political
advertising and we walk through the
legal analysis including what is
political advertising we always have to
include a disclaimer that that
implicitly language is no longer the law
of the land and we walk through the case
law there to explain to these folks that
that word no longer is applicable so we
think there would be some value in in
just having that word removed from the
statute
um
uh political advocacy organization
we
we've found that this raised an
interesting point of interpretation
because it the these organizations
trigger the
um need to
file with the state when they spend two
thousand five hundred dollars on
Communications
um this raises a a little bit of an
interesting disconnect where we're
wondering
we're making the determination of what
constitutes a communication
um what constitutes a payment for a
communication for example if a payment
is made but not given with the explicit
purpose of a communication that's it's
not labeled or for lack of a better word
earmarked for the purpose of
communication but it is subsequently
used for communication is that something
that that organization needs to report
um versus not
we think that
clarifying that language could be could
be helpful to folks that are going to
fall into that
um the category of a political advocacy
organization there did you want to add
anything okay
um
we wanted to briefly address HB
um 195.
um to raise the point that the the bill
does not
substantially change the definition of
um what a political advocacy
organization is
um and so we wanted to raise the
question of what
what the this body is aiming to achieve
with that and
um what what
goal is being sought with changing that
definition because we did not believe
that after looking at that looking at
the other definitions under 664
um two and one of what constitutes an
organization that there was not a
substantial shift there in in what
constituted a um a political advocacy
organization
um
there is a requirement for a written
consent on receipt of contributions we
just wanted to raise with his body that
we and it appears that the secretary of
state is in the same place we have not
heard of anybody complying with that
requirement
um
we they're not any instances that I'm
aware of
um again so we just just wanted to raise
that for this body
so the only other thing I'd add about
that is we do understand that there are
when candidates or political committees
may receive contributions that
they weren't aware of the fact that the
source of the contribution before they
received it was controversial
for some reason so it may be for
um and I'm going to forget the letters
of the com the cryptocurrency
yes and so when you have situations like
that then campaigns want to return those
contributions or they want to use them
for another purpose like give them to a
charitable purpose
so it could be that this language is in
there for individuals to be able to say
that they didn't provide written consent
to accept a contribution like that
because they weren't aware of the source
sometimes it could also be a situation
where
individuals may have given contributions
with different names so if you happen to
have a hyphenated name like Ann Edwards
Parker and I gave contributions under
Ann Edwards and then I gave
contributions under Ann Parker if
someone doesn't know me close enough
they may not realize that I've
contributed more than my share during
any election cycle
so it may be that that provision is a
safe harbor
for individuals but we did just want to
point out to you that like the Secretary
of State's office we're not sure anyone
thank you
um thank you check my question do you
know where that requirement is I quickly
scanned but I'm not very good at
multitasking if you could give me one
moment
so you
that that is under 664 colon 4 Roman 5
section 5.
foreign
thank you
and just to clarify did you have
anything further representative Lane
just wanted to make sure I didn't want
to interrupt you
um so finally um the last point that we
wanted
um to raise before this body was under
RSA 6647 I've quoted
um the language there that we are just
we have read to interpret that if a
political Committee of a party is
supporting a candidate then the
candidate would not need to disclose how
much that political committee has
supported them again not a point of
illegality or anything that we're
raising but we did just want to bring to
this body's attention that that's that
is how we are interpreting that wording
in 664 colon seven
foreign
very final issue that we don't have on
here is we issued a letter regarding
campaign Finance during the last cycle
and in that letter we put a chart in
that and so now with some of the review
of the changes to the statute and
upcoming changes the information in that
chart is not accurate as to how we would
be enforcing the law at this time
so we will be updating that chart but we
have not updated it yet
go ahead thank you
um thanks for all your work on this and
for your help as we
know any guidance as we review this
section of the of the
um
of election law
and uh
and I have just two two questions one is
about late reports
um roughly speaking if you're to guess
what fraction of late reports are a few
weeks late or a few days late let's say
less than two months late and what
fraction are more than two months sleep
um I am I am speculating
um I I don't have a hard number for you
but I would say based based on my
conversations with um Jill who is the
the point person on most of this
um the majority of the ones that are
filed late are are within within days or
weeks of um of the filing date
we're not my recollection is that we're
not seeing a what I would call a
significant number that are extremely
well beyond
um reporting deadlines
to and while that's accurate I I believe
one of the other points is especially
with candidates candidates don't have to
report until the Wednesday before the
campaign so if they're a few days late
that means they could be after the
election
um
oh you want to jump in
on the illegible reports and on the
reports with math errors there was a
sense that some small number of
candidates might be doing that
strategically in order to create opacity
so that their finances aren't really
visible
um is do you sometimes suspect that a
small number of candidates are filing
late for that with that strategic view
yes at times we have thought that that
thank you uh going back to the
distinction between candidate and
candidate committee I think that was
um 2B I'm not mistaken
um from an enforcement standpoint would
it make a difference
um and because we've been talking about
that as well and I'm just wondering from
an enforcement standpoint is there any
so um obviously I'll turn this over to
attorney Edwards if she has anything to
add after this
what that would help with is we've we
have raised a number of points here that
um are aimed at the the simple goal of
cutting down confusion
um and just that alone is going to cut
down on errors it's going to cut down on
the time that we spend going through
these so that the my understanding is
that the candidate versus candidate
committee that is a point that we raise
that we believe would help to cut down
on confusion and the
compacting errors that can result from a
sense of confusion but I don't believe
there would be significant enforcement
concerns beyond that okay thank you
and if I could just add I do believe
that so one of the challenges from the
candidate's position is and as the
deputy secretary of state has raised
recently there is confusion between the
need to register the need to report
and it they become conflated and then it
becomes confusing to people so
candidates currently don't have to
register a candidate committee has to
register both a candidate and Bo and a
candidate committee have to report and
so in order for a candidate to use the
online campaign Finance system they do
have to register to use the system but
that's it's a difference that might make
a difference to some candidates because
they feel like they don't have to
register and they shouldn't have to
register because they're doing things on
their own
and that they'll report their receipts
and expenditures
otherwise in accordance with the law but
it does cause confusion because when
especially when new candidates are
becoming involved in the process and
they're looking at it and they're trying
to figure out which they have to do
we're happy to answer questions the
Secretary of State's office is happy to
answer questions but it would just be
helpful if we could come to an agreement
where
the law was clearer on that issue and I
think that that's a decision for the
and thank you another big picture
question
um
and I'm curious about whether in your
office you you ever
um just kind of hit yourselves in the
head and think gosh you know there are
ways of just evading this entire system
of of reporting
um that we can't do anything about
because of the way the law is written
and not written and
um you know if the legislature really
cared about transparency and and
tracking
um donations out of a kind of
anti-corruption in uh you know interest
it would address this and and if so and
be curious to know what what those uh
what gives rise to that kind of reaction
so I think as we always say and we have
no reason not to say it New Hampshire
runs good elections we don't believe
that there are organizations that are
I guess I wouldn't use a word corruption
for anything I we don't see any evidence
of that but there are definitely ways of
skirting the system so it doesn't take
very much to become a political
committee and if you stay under the
funding amounts of twenty five hundred
dollars or a thousand dollars depending
on which type of political committee or
5000 you are you don't have to report
and you don't have to register and so we
do have organizations that do do that
and they do smaller mailers and they
have multiple political committees and
they're doing that because they can keep
all of those committees under a level
and therefore they don't have to report
there's nothing unlawful about doing
that
but it's there and again as we always
promote the point of campaign Finance is
to make sure that the public has the
ability to determine as much as possible
within the bounds of the law who is
supporting a candidate or who is
supporting an issue or opposing a
candidate or opposing an issue so it's
important to have that information
available as much as possible it is one
of the reasons why you'll see like in
the last Town elections in Municipal
elections
the individuals don't actually have to
form a political committee and they
don't have to report their expenditures
but they still have to identify the
organization in a meaningful manner on
signs and on mailers and phone calls
that they put out and we track down on
that and it takes a it's a lot of effort
in a short period of time because it's
really important for people to
understand whether the mailers they're
receiving are from their neighbors who
are concerned about I don't know the new
power plant or the new dump going into
the landfill going in place or whether
it's somebody from out of town or out of
state who's supporting that so
I don't that's one of the reasons why we
suggested that if political committees
are going to be active in an election
cycle we believe the political committee
should have to at least register even if
they don't have to report their numbers
to a certain point they should have to
register
and we'd also say that based on some of
our investigations it's really expensive
to do a political mailer so unless
they're doing something that's being
done on a local level and have found a
really great bargain it's it's costing
about three to four thousand dollars to
do a good size political mailing in a
community or a small part of the county
if you're doing a larger
uh political mailer you're well over ten
thousand dollars so there's a lot of
I have a question
uh again or at least a rough estimate
uh how many instances of
improperly identified political
advertising do you see in a given
election cycle roughly
so in the last so this has become our
full-time business and part of what we
did was we sort of
um
we didn't swear them in but we started
asking for the Public's health help in
2022 in particular and so we issue as we
started tracking mailer complaints that
we were getting we started putting out
daily press releases or every other day
press releases outlining the information
that we were finding out because as I
said these Anonymous mailers tend to go
out in the two-week time period before
the election and the the thought is
we're not going to be able to figure out
who it is and it's become a mission for
us to do that and what we found is by
bringing in members of the public we can
pretty quickly get extra hands on this
and people seem to be interested in
helping so we we
I mean I don't even know we had
during this last Municipal cycle so
there are three times that the
municipalities can vote they can vote
the towns they can vote in March and
April and May and in all three of those
we had at least
two or three for each one and in March I
think at one point we were running 15
of them that were Anonymous mailers and
while that doesn't sound like a lot it's
hard to track that down because we do we
have limited information in order to use
and we have criminal investigators in
our office and we put the criminal
investigators on those
those mailers so it's during the 2022
election
we had some
but I don't we didn't have as many it
tends to be us an item that's used more
in the Municipal elections and it's you
including the city elections then it is
but even
I mean actually as I say that we still
had
um we still had mailers and signs there
were a lot of signs in 2022 that went up
for the major elections the Statewide
elections that didn't have disclaimers
on them so we have to track those down
too I you know I don't think we've ever
had
if I ballpark this we've never had more
than 50 at a time but we may have had as
many as 25 during an election cycle
between 25 and 30.
when an option there for the big mailers
you know they're done they're usually
done by a printing shop we're not
talking about something Jet
um what an option there be to find the
printer
that is definitely an option if we had
that in a law that one of the challenges
is many of those
mailings are done out of state so we
have to cross state borders to find
those individuals and we right now are
in the process of dealing with one
organization that has done a mailer out
of Massachusetts and it's a lot it's a
challenge to do that and so I I can tell
you that on some of the large mailers
that happened in 2020
we were
um we have print shops that are out in
the Midwest
that we're dealing with
full
but we assuming you can find I
understand it's difficult to find them
when they go like I get it but we do
actually have the ability to legally we
would have the ability if it was in the
law to find them
you could because they are okay and then
the question is whether we can actually
get the fine to apply to them because
they're out of state but yes and there
are there are a fair amount of printers
in the state of New Hampshire and in
order to make sure that I'm not
maligning anyone they the out-of-state
printers don't necessarily know the
state law and they rely on the
individuals who are requesting the
mailers to provide them with the state
law so that's one of the challenges
there in the state of New Hampshire the
printers generally understand the state
law and they know what's required on
there in disclosure and so when we talk
with them there are times that they have
been told not to
disclose the individual and then we have
broader conversations about why that is
and there's just so you know generally
there's a case called uh McIntyre the
state of Maine versus McIntyre which Mr
McIntyre decided to go out he was very
angry about an issue on the ballot he
went out and he photocopied a whole
bunch of Flyers against the issue and he
stuck him under people's windshields at
the grocery store parking lot in order
to show his discontent and try to get
people to vote against it he was allowed
to do that and because he did it on his
own he was allowed to do that and not
put his name on the bottom of it though
he had been sued for failing to disclose
so people are protected under McIntyre
if they're an individual so if I choose
to to vote against
whether maple syrup should be our state
treat then I can go and do that and and
function on my own I can even go to a
printer and pay the printer as long as
the printer is just printing the copies
for me but if Matt and I did that
together we're now a political committee
and at that point we have to put a
disclosure on the bottom saying Matt and
Ann are against this and this is why
they're you know here's their statement
so it's you just it I offer all of that
information because it is there are ways
to for people to continue to assert
their first amendment rights and do that
without having to disclose who they are
and why they're doing it and those
investigations take us even a longer
period of time because we then have to
protect those people's names when we
determine who they are but it becomes
that's when we hit resistance from the
local printers because the local
printers understand that too and so we
have to go through a process to be able
to confirm that no one has committed a
you may not be able to answer this but
we are trying to deal with the fact that
there are nine different and try and
come up with a generic
um definition and what I keep running
into when I try to do that is that in
most jurisdictions including hours
because there's been this creation of
all these different kinds of packs
that they uh segregate out and have
special rules for those different kind
of packs which I'm guessing is the
reason we have all the different
spending in the reporting because they
do you I've got two two very good
lawyers in front of me are is there any
way that you can think of that we can
simplify it because you what triggered
it was when you said you referenced the
two of you and that is a committee
and if we do that that's one question
and then second one would be how then do
we differentiate
what they're doing is it what their
expenditures aren't going for like
independent expenditures or is it going
towards
um is it a political uh like the
candidate committee
and and can they I we are having a
problem trying to identify how to
simplify it
and you're not alone
we we are happy to continue to have
conversations with Secretary of State's
office about this we have been talking
about it and
um it's it is a challenge because back
in the olden days we began with just a
political committee and it was if it was
two people together doing something then
they were a political committee and
still at that time we didn't want to
have everybody have to necessarily
register unless they started spending
money and so that's one of the reasons
why our suggestion is if we start maybe
with registration
and have everyone register at least we
know the entities that are out there and
we have combined two of your nine
already so we now have eight because
that this they're just too closely
aligned to not do that but then you end
up with a different expenditure level
and uh so we will continue to work with
the Secretary of State's office about
suggesting some language we don't have
an an immediate answer for you on that
but we too think it would be easier to
try to do that the challenge is as
you've identified representative Lane
there are
some of this is also overflow from
federal elections and and so these
different organizations who come into
New Hampshire usually only every two
years for the major elections come in
here and they want to understand how
they have to report if they have to
report and they like to have the
reporting systems look similar across
the states because it just makes it
easier for them on a national level
and I think that that is part of the
reasons why we have what we have and
that's why we have some different levels
but it doesn't mean that New Hampshire
can't
yes I have a thank you for taking my
question I have a question about two
other types of committee I'm not
there's a type that that's major
purposes influencing elections
and another type that uh
influenza collections is not its major
purpose and they have two different
spending thresholds at which they have
to begin to report
right yes from the enforcement side is
that add any difficulty in determining
which is which in particular cases it
certainly
it it causes challenges in figuring out
whether they've reported on time based
on what it is that they have
what their spending limit is the
political committee that has its major
purposes electioneering we have now
determined that in enforcement we are
going to combine that with a regular
political committee because they there
just doesn't seem to be enough of a
distinction there there doesn't seem to
be any legal distinction in our mind and
reviewing it
and
why there's a political committee whose
I mean we can think of different
organizations that do things so if I'm
an attorney I'm a member of the New
Hampshire Bar Association the New
Hampshire Bar Association does Lobby
and it doesn't do political
electioneering but at lobbies and so
that's the type of organization there
could be a corporation that has a um
segregated account that's the other type
of organization one of the other types
of organizations so we can see why these
all came out this way but it doesn't
necessarily mean that we couldn't
combine some of them
in into
into one or into a couple of them
instead of having so many separate ones
that is one of the challenges that the
Secretary of State's office is facing in
working on creating a new campaign
Finance system because there are so many
different committees and if somebody
chooses the wrong one then that causes
another challenge
so
we're not exactly sure why they were
established this way except for the fact
that we're sure that some organization
came in uh and it could be I could see
one of the political committees without
the major purpose not for electioneering
could be one of the get out the vote
committees who came in and is is doing
some activities that might be
electioneering on a certain party
perhaps but is generally here as a get
out the vote initiative
for college students or for individuals
working at grocery stores or something
like that so
I don't have a good answer I don't think
for your question that's fine I don't
have a good answer either
I I did have the impression reading
about the different reporting
this requirements for when you need to
register because there's different
expenditure thresholds
for when you need to report and there's
some cases where it's expenditures or
receipts
right so it seemed to me that it might
be helpful to
be more uniform in those requirements
but I mean that seems to be the basic
distinction between the different types
of committees
yes okay and it and it also is again it
conflates that those terms of
registration and Reporting together
which isn't necessarily helpful because
it does it means that peop that
organizations I say people but it's
always it's organizations or people can
out be out doing activities and as long
as they stay under that reporting
threshold they're never registering
and so until something goes wrong or
until someone I some organization or
entity and identifies them they can be
there and be involved in New Hampshire
elections without being identified but
under the law they're still required to
register
okay I've I've read it like four times
so far it's still
getting it loaded into
useful memory well and that's and that
is exact that's the challenge with it it
really is it's the the fact that they
don't have to register until they hit a
okay thank you
for helping me understand that better
immediate solution to me which I'm not
sure is really practical is if you
register you report
and everybody you know
or you have a really throat low
threshoff or every threshold for
everybody but I don't know if anybody
even does that
I'm just throwing it out but when you
said that and I know he's going to
disagree with me no no I'm not going to
disagree I'm I'm are you talking about
okay I don't I don't hate that yeah I
mean because the challenge is excuse me
the way it works now is if I'm running a
political committee and my reporting
level is 1500.
I and I hit 1600 by close to the end of
the election cycle I now have to report
I have to report back to dollar one so
somewhere I better be tracking all of
that information but we just
traditionally in New Hampshire have not
had organizations reporting from dollar
one
a voluntary organization could do that
if it chooses to it's
and a candidate would end up doing that
if a candidate was making a report but
the other political committees do not
end up having to do that if they're not
believe it or not representatively I
actually don't hate that idea
especially we won't do it today but
especially in the air of what happened
in the budget transparency is going to
become very important
uh representative Rossman so you don't
hate that idea would it be a little more
specific as to what that idea is
um basically
representative Lane's idea of if you
file you report okay um thank you I
I'm not sure if I like that idea or not
okay he does hate that two partners for
just a moment we don't want to use up
here the idea of having everyone
involved register
Maybe but I have to think about that
some more anyway I think representative
Muirhead had a question
cute I have a question about limits
contribution limits
um and uh
and one is rolling over funds from from
campaign to campaign from cycle to cycle
which might allow a candidate to raise
money simultaneously for a previous
cycle and a present cycle
and and there's also the possibility
that say if let's say you raise money
for the executive Council race and
somebody maxes out
um and you you rate you have a surplus
and you roll that Surplus into a
gubernatorial race
did the person who maxed out for your
executive Council race are they now able
to max out again to the governor's race
even though their money is in a sense
so that's those are never easy questions
to answer sort of as hypotheticals but
generally if they're if the executive
Council race is completed and there is a
surplus that Surplus can be moved into
another
another campaign so if it were the
primary and I ran for executive Council
in the primary and I won and I had
five thousand dollars in my
my
um
I have let's say ten thousand dollars in
my Treasury and I want to move it all
into the general if if some of that ten
thousand dollars
perhaps most of that ten thousand
dollars is a five thousand dollar
contribution from an individual then
that person can't give again to me in
the general election because there that
is there is a and arguably there is a
clear connection that I collected I was
allowed to collect more I just couldn't
spend it during the primary period
no wait a minute if I I collected it for
the primary I had the ability to spend
the money in the primary I can't and I
can roll it into the general election I
can't then collect another
wait a minute now see now I'm gonna get
myself tripped up so
actually I can do that that was a bad
example scratch that example so you can
but if if at the end of the executive
councils I get elected I don't get
elected I have ten thousand dollars that
can go into a gubernatorial fund to
begin so when I decide to run for
governor in two years I have the ability
to do that that money then isn't tracked
in the same way it's only tracked
between the three stages of exploratory
Primary in general
and you can collect in the exploratory
space you could collect fifteen thousand
dollars from one person but you have to
allot it so that you're only spending
five in the exploratory five in the
primary and five in the general
but you and you can't collect any more
in any of those phases from the same
person who made that fifteen thousand
there's another thing you were you had a
question
uh
you had a question but you have a
follow-up okay
thank you um
and and there are limitations as I
understand it right now on individual
contributions but not on contributions
from certain kinds of committees do that
does that disparity make sense from the
side of enforcement
so from the side of enforcement we just
enforce what's in the law it's a public
policy decision as to whether or not you
want to allow
on what levels you want to have for the
ability to
don't contribute funds from different
organizations
um thank you
um we haven't really talked about this
but
um there has been a lot in the on the
federal level issues around coordination
between campaigns and super what's
called super Pacs has that come up in
any of the enforcement in any of your
Enforcement cases do you see that here
well we do see super Pacs they tend to
be in the uh
the presidential election year and in
the midterm year elections so super Pacs
are here
and they contribute money do we we look
at coordination we look at independent
expenditures depending on what's
occurring generally we haven't had any
significant problems with them
but they are here and we do what we do
I'd like to rephrase representative
muirhead's question because I think what
he was trying to get to was does the
structure of
um unlimited contributions pack to pack
transfers create the potential to get
around the spirit of the law of our
contribution limits is that is that a
better way of expressing that there we
go I don't hate that yes there we go
so I I guess we're back to we understand
that that's what happens with them and
again it's a policy Choice that's why we
in the last
I don't know six election Cycles have
issued letters making sure it's very
clear how we read the election laws and
what that means with respect to
contributions so that the legislature
understands that's how we're
interpreting the law if you want to
choose to change those contribution
levels that's fine we're happy to
enforce them that way but it's not our
decision as to whether or not
thank you is there any limitation to how
much a candidate can roll over from a
municipal election to a Statewide
election they run for mayor of Franklin
and raised two million dollars and then
run for for governor could they roll it
all over if they didn't spend it in
Franklin yeah
and thank you and is there but there is
you can't roll money from Municipal and
state elections into Federal campaigns
answer to that question because that's
I want to follow up on that so in the
city of Manchester we have no
contribution limits so somebody could
raise an unlimited money for mayor and
then roll that into per se a race for
governor
Unlimited
back to I hate answering these questions
in a hypothetical but right now at the
top of my head I don't see a reason why
they couldn't
but it I mean I guess the question is
yeah actually so my one caveat is in
Municipal elections the town elections
there are not political committees and
so
I'm not sure how those funds are being
reported in the the city elections I
don't know how
how they're holding those but the the
city elections also aren't required
they're not a political committee so
I have a question
uh one of the thoughts we've discussed
relates to the different phases of an
election cycle
correct me if I get this wrong but but I
think we can talk about exploratory or
pre-primary phase is one and there's the
primary uh phase and then the general
election phase is am I getting that
correct yes that's how we Define them
right we've uh
discussed the thought of just having an
election cycle phase numbers getting rid
of those distinctions
and having one overall contribution
limit which we're not talking about
changing the overall total at this point
so my question that's the background my
question is with doing things with just
one phase for the entire election cycle
with that
make the enforcement of of things
more effective or efficient or less so
I'm not I understand
that you folks enforce the policy set by
the legislature that's and I understand
and agree with the sense of that but how
would that affect the enforcement would
it make for Less confusion Maybe
I I believe that it would make for Less
confusion I think it would make
reporting easier for candidates as well
because they do have to identify and
segregate funds in order to match the
three phases of the process and so they
wouldn't have to do that I would say
generally most of our candidates are
pretty well educated on this now so it's
much easier in enforcing the three
phases than it was 10 years ago where
people were constantly
putting money in the different phases
and it wasn't it wasn't as it wasn't as
well understood at that time but I think
that if you put it all together and you
had so if you I don't know what you'd
want to use let's just use the current
figure so if it's fifteen thousand
dollars and somebody can collect that in
the
exploratory phase as long as the
candidates understand that as they're
coming into the general election and
really looking for money they can go
back to those people who gave them 15
000 in the beginning then uh that's that
that you then have to have we'd probably
have to modify the reporting Cycles
because currently under the law the this
each end of a cycle so the end of a
prime the primary campaign ends 10 days
after the primary and then you have to
have the second committee set up for the
general election so you'd want to do
something where maybe you combine those
two
reporting periods but they
there that would could easily be done
thank you on the rolling over if I were
to raise
money to to run for select board and
Hanover which doesn't require any
reporting at all
and then I were to run I don't know some
sort of State campaign like for the
legislature are there any requirements
for the rate at which that money is
rolled over could I just kind of drip it
into my state campaign as needed and
otherwise keep it in this unregistered
unreported unlimited local you know
account that I use to run for select
board so so in other words I have 500
000 in this in this account and when I
incur five thousand dollars of expenses
I roll five thousand into this state
account so that you never really see how
elections I don't know what that thing
is that you're holding your money in and
so that part is concerning and would be
concerning because I don't
I don't even
I assume you're not a registered
political committee because you're not
required to be a registered political
Committee in Municipal elections so
you're running a bank account of some
type now I I say that with the
understanding that in the case of some
Municipal elections particularly mayor
elections where they tend to be more
expensive though at times those
individuals will create political
committees so that they have their funds
going into a political committee account
and they will do that and they will and
at that point they clearly are in line
with being able to make contributions in
accordance with the state law with
respect to your account that you'd be
holding in Hanover that's got a half a
million dollars in it for your
slackman's race and what you're doing
with it I think that we would be having
a lot of conversations about what that
is and and how that's functioning
because I'm back to I don't like to
answer campaign Finance it questions as
a hypothetical I'm I'm not sure what you
could do with it but I also am not sure
that you couldn't just contribute it all
and I don't think and if you didn't if
there there's no it's one of the
challenges with Municipal elections
there are no deadlines on anything with
respect to what you have to do with
those funds and how you can hold those
funds and how you report on those funds
because there just are no rules around
those and for the most part it's because
when somebody's running for
um dog catcher or seleckman in a
municipality they're not raising
necessarily a lot of funds but sometimes
in some of those elections like mayoral
elections they may be raising a lot of
funds
Mr chairman I have to excuse myself I
have to take my child to uh actually
your neck of the woods
um so I apologize but I have to I have
do we have any other questions from the
subcommittee
I mean you've been very generous with
your time and we really appreciate it
it's been very helpful the write-up also
very very helpful next
thank you we'll be
we'll be Perry States off
more we can do we're happy to help so
last call for questions
okay well thank you very very much both
Miss Hennessy is there anything you'd
like to share with us any thoughts that
have been stimulated by this discussion
if if so you're welcome to share them
good morning Erin Hennessey deputy
secretary of state
um Mr chair I mentioned to you not in
this meeting that our department is
putting together some suggested changes
based on what we've heard you speak
about based on what we think would be
helpful to help clarify 664 and based on
what the AG's office just testified to
so I My Hope Is that we'll have this to
you before your next meeting are you
planning on meeting again after
your next meeting we haven't decided yet
okay we'll have to discuss it amongst us
thank you we
I think our next meeting on the 29th
uh excuse me the 27th
thank you 14 plus 13 is 27 all the time
anyway we'll be discussing the direction
we're taking in the future in that
meeting okay
thank you
uh we have a question if you have time
I don't know if you received them can I
just send you those because
we had talked about working with the
Secretary of State on those so I'm happy
to send them to you sure sure that would
thank you very much for your time we
I don't I don't know how we're going to
get this done with only one more meeting
but miracles happen
I think if we're working on documents I
don't think we necessarily have to have
a meeting and I think working document
we can share working documents without
violating
uh
the right to know law but yeah we'll
make sure of that okay but we can
discuss we can discuss that next meeting
I'm not
adamant about how we go forward this
uh we would like to all come up with
something useful out of this and I think
we're going to be able to oh I think so
just bringing clarity
and reducing the potential for confusion
do you know whether a subgroup like this
is permitted to meet via Zoom
or remotely
I know that was a you know in context of
the pandemic
uh remote meetings acquired a certain
kind of controversiality but I think in
this context it's I don't have a
definitive I don't have a real opinion
on that at this point would have to find
out
it'd be easier to call a
essentially a conference call if we just
needed to quickly
connect and not really work hard for two
hours
I'll do my best to find out
well I'd like
and if we if we need to meet a few more
my sense is we want to work on some sort
of draft
which we could exchange you know by
email and then come together to really
discuss it and and
invite comment and and feedback on it
from
others and so some of the work we can do
as it were in our studies
I'd have to we should probably all
reread 91a I recall there was a an
exception for working
versions of documents but I'd have to
reread it and would be safest if we got
an opinion from someone whose business
it is
should
please come on in we would welcome your
input
triggering the 91a not to a quorum up
the subcommittee no a quorum of the
subcommittee
no you can't do that either because you
you can't do it sequentially so that
effectively it just
I was a selectment for three years so I
remember some of this pretty clearly
reply all is the the sticking point
right
reply and then it's like whoops reply
all is a quorum and that's has to be
well thank you thank you very much for
your taking the effort to come down and
clarify this for us
all right
well there I I just took on the task of
finding out and we just found out
excellent
I can imagine Connie sending me
and I don't mean to
you know cast any aspersions a
half-baked draft
that then I would work on a little bit
which that I could send to you
when you could put it in your oven for a
little while
and send it to somebody else and then we
could say it's been baked enough that we
want to actually
get together in lob and discuss it as a
group
and and so that might be a way of of
working on it we should all read RSA 91a
again in detail
and then seek advice
as long as it's not a quorum
but if if you sh if this is my
understanding from when I was a
selectman if if you two share something
you can you can do that because you're
not a quorum right however if you then
sequentially move it on to somebody else
I'm not sure that's
kosher yeah we don't want to even look
like we're trying to get around anything
we all know that
so yeah the two of you are not a quorum
so
you're free to discuss these things okay
all right do we have anything else that
we wish to discuss here as a
no I guess at some point we're going to
have to talk about what the Senate
Finance did but we can talk about that
yeah that was interesting yeah
so yeah yep okay are you are you aware
of what the
it was the unlimited
when they when they changed the packs to
right
I've got that you know somewhere else
but anyway
uh then if we have nothing we need to
discuss further we can adjourn are you
agreeable to that colleagues
all right then we will adjourn this
meeting at 11 26 a.m We Are adjourned
and thank you to members of the public
and deputy secretary for